So in the intermediate stages of the merge,
we have all the SMs working on independent merges, one SM per merge.
At some point though, when we get to the very top of the merge tree,
we only have a very small number of merges left or eventually, just one.
We have a single task, but it's a very big task. Now, why is this bad?
Why is it problematic for efficiency that we only have one merging task remaining?
So why is this bad? Why is it problematic for efficiency that we have only one merging task remaining?
Well, could be a number of things. We could have lots of idle threads per SM,
We could just have lots of SMs that are idle, or we might suffer from very high branch divergence.
So please check the one you think is the best answer.